all right one nashville couple is
harnessing the generosity of their
massive social media following
to leave huge tips for strangers
videographer lexi burke
and her husband country musician austin
burke captured the moment they surprised
people with tips of at least
five hundred dollars the couple uses
tick tock
to raise the money to help americans
financially hurt by the pandemic
they spoke to our errol barnett about
how the challenge grew
to help so many people errol good
morning
good morning look the kids call this the
venmo challenge
lexia austin burke effectively just
asked their
more than one million followers on tick
tock to
send in their spare change anywhere from
25 cents to a
dollar well week on a week thousands of
people have done
exactly that and now from waiters to
uber drivers people's
lives have actually been transformed
folks who didn't expect it
at a time of uncertainty for so many
if i give you a thousand dollars that
cover it a thousand dollars
tipping strangers one thousand dollars
has become the norm for nashville couple
lexi and austin burke
are you serious
it's their version of a popular
tick-tock trend known as the venmo
challenge
where users crowdfund small mobile
payments for tips
i noticed different users were asking
their followers to venmo them
so i just decided to do this venmo
challenge but
for the service industry lexi and austin
have both waited tables before
so they know how essential tips are for
servers
i randomly got a 1 000 tip a few years
back
so that was something i had always
wanted to do to pay it forward
lexi began paying it forward with this
simple request to her followers
if every follower then mows me 50 cents
we could leave
a massive tip for somebody her venmo
account filled with donations
totaling more than three thousand
dollars
did you expect lexi that you would even
raise
the amount you did the first time
absolutely not
those receiving the tips were just as
shocked
the newlywed couple has now raised more
than 155
thousand dollars sharing it with more
than 100 strangers
we just did one on thanksgiving day we
ordered some pizza
the recipient was so sweet and so
gracious
we had a server she broke down because
she just said she unfortunately was
getting evicted from her home
[Music]
we made a pact that number one we would
give all the money out
and number two that we would just leave
it up to god to who
inspired by all those that gave to him
nail technician tommy nguyen decided to
pay
his tip forward i split it out i gave it
some to my family i gave it back to my
dance community
how much of the 1 000 did you keep for
yourself
50 bucks there's just so many people
that i wanted to give out so many people
touched by a simple act of kindness this
isn't from
lexi or myself this is from thousands
and thousands of people that
genuinely care about you and love you
what's your hope for the people who've
been on the receiving end of these gifts
my hope for them is just to keep doing
what they're doing
whether you're serving or a nurse you're
so appreciated and i feel like this year
we've all been able to come together and
hopefully a lot of them have talked
about paying it forward too you
[Music]
and keep in mind they do get permission
every time they record someone and
surprise them with a massive
fat tip lexi and austin are fundraising
for their last round of 2020 but
keep in mind they do get something in
return take a look at this video clip
it's tommy and lexi
dancing to lizzo's truth hurts the two
are now taking dance classes together
and they credit this challenge and the
entire experience
for bringing them close of course their
hope
is that this becomes contagious and
everyone effectively
pays it forward tony wow thank you sarah
yeah that's so lovely but go lexi and
austin it just shows you because
everybody can give 50 cents
i i like how they're starting with that
but it just shows you how kindness
begets kindness
that's true do it for somebody and you
think now what can i do to help somebody
else and seeing all those reactions
together
we do need a venmo challenge in congress
though for this next stimulus building
come through exactly
maybe if they filmed it online the
people on capitol hill you're right